hello everyone I'm Ed McMahon and now
here's Johnny it's time for a Clash of
the Kings or King as the case may be it
chapter two is heading into theaters
soon and to honor everyone's favorite
googly eyed clown we decided to
celebrate his creator mr. Stephen King
on this show celebrations get
competitive so we're pitting Kings best
theatrically released horror film
adaptations against each other in a
winner-take-all bracket style brawl get
your popcorn ready Georgie here's how it
works
we took the 16 highest rated Stephen
King horror movies on the tomato meter
and seated them accordingly so if you're
a fan of Stephen Kingsmore
cult classics like a dreamcatcher a
children of the corn sorry they're not
showing up for any where kids go out in
the field and play from this bracket of
16 we'll Whittle it down to 8 and then 4
and then 2 and finally we'll crown the
all-time greatest Stephen King scary
flick friendly reminder although being
in prison or bullied by Kiefer
Sutherland is scary Kings drama
adaptations are not a part of this list
so no Shawshank no stand by me no
environmentally-conscious miles and if
you're wondering what's the original it
released in theaters I will simply
answer with a polite no but shout out to
the og Pennywise who is played by the
legend mr. Tim Curry one plus one plus
two plus one even if you were right
that will be one plus one plus two plus
one not 1 plus 2 plus 1 plus 1 let's run
through these matchups and find out
who's advancing to the next round the
top seeded Kerry is going up against the
16 seed Silver Bullet Kerry with Stephen
King's first horror novel the one that
did well enough for him to quit teaching
and the film was his first big-screen
adaptation this is why we have all those
other movies to talk about thank you see
money Silver Bullet on the other hand
remember that one mysterious death
started happening in a sleepy town so
Corey Haim and his uncle have to stop a
werewolf who plays his uncle who else
but Gary Busey tada
and despite my affinity for
all things Busey and my love of Coors
Light Silver Bullet is being stopped by
the kevlar known as Carrie Carrie
advances this [ __ ] look [ __ ]
look next up we have Creepshow versus
christine creep show was kings
screenwriting debut and directed by the
harm master himself george romero it
played then and now as a horror comedy
anthology with an eclectic cast it
includes how Holbrook Ted Danson and
Leslie Nielsen I love it creepy at weird
kids however I would have to say
Christine is the better-known property
simply based on the fact that Christine
is a car that gets picked on and
develops a revenge hungry mind of its
own in short this movie can scare anyone
who's ever driven a car any Plymouth
owners out there shout out to you buckle
up the next battle is between two more
recent King movies it from 2017 versus
pet cemetery from 2019 both their
re-imaginings from their original
adaptations and while Pet Sematary did
have salad reviews it was a worldwide
phenomenon
dominating the box office and cancelling
clowned birthday party performances at a
record pace Pennywise gets the win we
move on to the shining versus the dark
half and to be clear this is the shining
from 1979 not the TV movie starring
Steven Weber from wings underrated
sitcom you burned Ellen's house to the
ground
oops speaking of underrated the dark
half has a premise some might say spawn
from Stephen King's owned writer fears
Timothy Hutton plays an author whose
pseudonym starts actually killing people
sorry
and while we're on the subject of
authors how about that Jack Torrance
dedicated family man and boy does he
work hard
The Shining is the all-time classic that
inspired generations of horror lovers
and that's why the shining is gonna move
on
speaking of hotels our next fracas is
1408 vs. Cujo now Cujo is definitely the
more well-known property and it has a
permanent place and our cultural
zeitgeist however as the stepfather of a
dog I don't want to perpetuate any media
that portrays dogs as anything less than
the angels that they are 1408 may be the
lesser known horror film that features a
hotel but the paranoia of John Cusack's
character has a slow burn that doesn't
let up
14:08 gets to stay another night the
dead zone versus 1989's pet cemeteries
up next and remember how just defended
dogs yeah I don't feel the same way
about cats especially if they're dead
already
I'm totally cool with cats creeping up
the joint and the original Pet Sematary
had a massive effect on me as an
eight-year-old why because my aunt took
me to see it in the theater when I was
but eight I don't know why she did it it
still haunts me to this day
sorry Chris Walken Pet Sematary gets to
move on man we just can't escape pets
cat's eye is taking on the mist and the
former is another anthology from kings
mind and directed once again by George
Romero three stories all featuring the
same feline running around making things
uncomfortable and judging the humans
just like kitties do in real life
meanwhile the mist is so creepy and
dripping with societal metaphors that it
deserves to advance you stick with that
flick long enough and the payoff
features monsters and that gets very
very depressing the Miss advances and
any captain was watching this vid has
now turned it off thanks for the click
Garfield our last matchup in this round
featured misery versus the 2013 remake
of Carrie this was a good remake of
Carrie and it had plenty of blood but
how in the world when I let misery lose
to a cockadoodie remake Paul Sheldon
finished his book he threw a snowball
strike and was on top of the world until
he wound up in a super fans bed yeah
misery will have plenty of company
because it gets the win and is moving on
to the Elite Eight he didn't get out of
the [ __ ] doodie car
time for the only date our first matchup
scary versus Christine a car that kills
people is a fun idea and gives all of us
Herbie the lovebug fans something to
think about but carrie has transcended
the horror genre and become an iconic
representation of how scary being a
teenager can be especially in that
family it's more relatable and thus
infinitely more terrifying plus I'd hate
to think that all that pig's blood went
to waste Kari advances to the final four
the next matchup will cause a lot of
comments how do I know this am i Dionne
Warwick no but these two flicks are all
times scary hits it versus the shining
wow it was an international money-making
juggernaut that rebooted at the right
time capitalizing on our love of
stranger things and our fear of clowns
it made 329 million dollars domestically
which more than doubles the Shining's
total yes I adjusted for inflation thank
you for a cloud that only shows up once
what every 27 years which makes it all
the more curious than I'm picking the
shining I know I know sometimes it just
comes down to which luck is scarier The
Shining has more all-time horrific
images that stay with you the twins the
big wheel the elevator the bartender the
bathtub get out of the tub lady you're
starting to prune and Plus oh poor
Shelley Duvall yeah both movies are hits
both have sequels coming out later this
year but the shining is advancing to the
next round
next up is 1408 vs. Pet Sematary this
one is an easy call for me
but let's doubt 1408 s impressive stats
first 237 million dollar total at the
box office
and its 79% fresh in the tomato meter
meanwhile Pet Sematary made 167 point 4
million at the box office and is just
below fresh at 52%
however 1408 is a creepy psychological
horror exploration that we saw and well
yeah ok it's pretty good Pet Sematary is
everywhere we all know what it is we're
born with that knowledge there's a place
that you do not bury anything sometimes
dead is better sometimes
also spoiler alert no one dies on screen
42 it it's just a wacky night in the
hotel room meanwhile Pet Sematary has
this I was only eight years old eight
pet cemeteries going to the final for
granting mommy
our last Elite Eight matchup features
the mist versus misery yeah I like the
mist and it gets credit for being fresh
seventy-two percent and having some
impressive monster awaited deaths
34 people eat it in this flick 34 well
done
fog spiders problem is the mist is
running into a buzz saw in her name
Annie Wilkes oh I hope I didn't wake you
misery is certified fresh at 90 percent
considered an all-time classic won
Academy Awards and even though that only
has two deaths in it we also see feet
get clubbed yeah
between that and Zelda I am limping out
of this studio today misery
gets the win the operation was called
hobbling you are looking live at the
Final Four so the film that started it
all Kari now faces its most daunting
challenge yet the Overlook Hotel most of
us were a little scared of prom anyway
so Kari had a leg up but as someone that
stays in a lot of hotels the shiny gets
in your head and never leaves why does
any hotel still have room 237 y'all
don't have a 13th floor but you're cool
with the dead zombie lady in the bathtub
get your priorities straight hotels
signed a loyal Bond boy member anyway
all due credit to the pair of Academy
Award nominated performances in carry
from [ __ ] Spacek and Piper Laurie but
the shining holds up as the scarier
flick this is despite the fact that the
shining not only earned zero Oscar
nominations Shelley Duvall and Stanley
Kubrick each received a Razzie
nomination not appreciated in its own
time or by the author but I'm here to
give the shining it's due all work and
no play makes Jack a dull boy but Jack's
movie is playing in the finals
and in the other Final Four matchup it's
a real underdog story but you don't want
to play with these dogs or these cats or
anything else buried in pet cemetery
it's misspelled but that's what it says
this film is such a cool concept and
features some truly chilling moments
both from events central to the plot and
from random backstories put in just to
give me nightmares I'm going to twist
your spine but misery has to a list
actors giving tremendous performances
including the oscar-winning turn for
Kathy Bates
we cannot overstate how important that
win was for horror movies
second only to comedies in terms of film
genres that simply don't get enough
credit come award season just ask Toni
Collette who I'm still upset wasn't
nominated for hereditary the film builds
suspense so well has some viscerally
terrifying moments and gave us a villain
for all times if there's a mountain
Rushmore for movie villains it's got to
be the Wicked Witch of the West Darth
Vader Annie Wilkes and Chet from weird
science you stood butt-wad misery
berries pet cemetery and moves on to the
finals I'm my number one fan and now
we've arrived at the championship game
Stephen King's all time theatrically
released horror film adaptations it all
comes down to misery vs the shining in
this corner we have a crazed author and
his opponent is someone who would
probably love his books jack versus
annie snow versus well more snow
to determine my ultimate Stephen King
movie I'm looking beyond all the
box-office accolades and performances
that got these flicks here to earn the
crown I'm looking into their all-time
legacy where do these films rank in the
pantheon of almighty horror cinema
misery was perhaps Kings most prized
possession or at least the one he was
most strict about optioning he only
wanted Rob Reiner to make the film and
that was only after Ryder did such a
fantastic job with another King story
stand by me
speaking of Rob Reiner misery success
was a reaffirmation that you didn't have
to be considered a horror director to
make a great scary flick Reiner was
coming off rom-com hits like When Harry
Met Sally and The Princess Bride when he
made misery but if you want to talk
about big-time directors venturing into
the world of horror enter Stanley
Kubrick despite the protests from King
himself The Shining has become a
cultural touchstone that resonates with
generations of movie lovers for example
how about the extended sequence in 2017
s ready player one that takes place in
the Overlook Hotel it's just another
reminder of how truly scary The Shining
is and how horrifying hotels can be at
3:00 a.m. if you see a bartender in the
middle of the night in a hotel it is a
ghost go back to your room
misery is an undisputed classic scary
movie it features unforgettable
performances spine-tingling suspense
wrought by Rob Reiner and the film can
claim what few horror movies can Academy
Awards meanwhile The Shining has found
its own place in the pop-culture lexicon
and that legacy only seems to grow
stronger with each passing year to be
one of the top films of both Stanley
Kubrick and Jack Nicholson's legendary
careers is no small feat and now to
declare my winner quick sidebar to
heighten the tension Barnes & Noble did
a cool article that ranked the king of
horror movies in terms of faithfulness
to their source material misery was the
most faithful and the shining was number
13 which makes it all the more nutty
that I'm proclaiming the shining as my
winner
it's a scariest one to me I know not to
go driving during a blizzard on
mountainous terrain but do not stay at
hotels come on I'm a comedian that's
unavoidable tickets of Mark Ellis
live.com the shining takes the prize and
just like they do for March Madness cue
the song one shining moment you reach
down inside
anything you say Lloyd anything you say
the good news is I'm not gonna sing
anymore the really good news is that all
of this is just my opinion Stephen King
certainly doesn't agree with me how
about you now it is your turn to vote
for the all-time best Stephen King
horror film adaptation we'll post our
bracket below all you have to do is
leave a comment below with your tape
what's the best what's the scariest
which movie if you wish was in sweet 16
any sleepwalker fans out there Salem's
Lot let us know right now thanks for
tuning in and remember kids if a giri
old lady made you cookies then got naked
she's probably a murderous clown have a
great day
[Music]
[Applause]